Ms,
perhaps the first or second day.
And my brother had been elected to the
congress and he asked me whether I
wanted a tour of,
of,
of Washington.
And I welcomed the,
uh,
the opportunity and he brought me around
to the House of Representatives and
brought me to the United States Senate,
brought me over to the Supreme Court of
the United States,
pointed out the White House along with
those magnificent monuments,
the Lincoln,
but Washington monument.
But he gave advice to me then,
which,
uh,
really,
stuck with me.
I was
probably 12 years old at the,
uh,
at the time,
and he said to look,
you'll,
you'll visit the buildings now.
You'll see these buildings.
That'd be,
but he said that the really importance
of this visit is that you take an
interest in what is happens inside these
buildings,
uh,
for the rest of your life.
And I thought,
well,
that's a nice sort of idea,
but,
uh,
you know,
when,
uh,
when are we going to get hot dogs or
something or other,
or go to a baseball or a football game.
But the resonance of that message,
uh,
stayed with me,
with me,
uh,
all of my life.
And,
uh,
it was good advice at that time.
And it's advice I share with a,
when young people come from a
Massachusetts,
uh,
and visit the,
the capital,
it's,
it's the way,
uh,
only way really our democracy is going
to work is if people take the interest,
take the time involved themselves in
the,
the political life of our country.
It's enormously.